time to have hulu
hey pretty people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries for the suicide
squad
uh suicide squad from james
don't forget the um gotta have that in
there this is the show where we talk
about our uh our behind the scenes
process thoughts and feelings about the
film we'll show you some deleted scenes
we'll answer some questions from viewers
like yourselves keep coming in the chat
and we'll tease you with next week's
honest trailer um you may have watched
us watch this movie for the first time
we did a watch along on this very
channel uh the other friday i don't know
what's time um and uh i think he could
get a sense from that that we all
definitely enjoyed ourselves um i would
just like to start by thanking uh
whatever alt-right chud got uh james
gunn briefly canceled so that he could
make this movie and guardians three it's
a round of applause to that person thank
you thank you mike cernovich we owe you
one thanks buddy oh sir no yeah thank
you sir no no no so we get uh we get
james gunn who is uh i'd say like the
creator of the marvel style of film but
his roots go into a much like harder r
direction so this was like i think the
best version of him this is him like a
softball down the middle for james gunn
you got your your hilarious violence uh
your quips your good character work and
just like
just like a silly light tone that still
gets really uh gnarly and kind of grind
house-y at times um just goes down so
well chocolate and peanut butter for me
what did you guys think about this film
yeah no this was another one i'm not
like uh i'm not super into the gore
we've talked about this before like i'm
not uh but this was done in such a like
great cartoony way like in that gun
style and yeah uh the way that he's able
to
balance all of these characters balance
motivations balance um
just so much going on and you still like
you come out of it feeling like you know
everyone um the deaths in this felt like
it mattered it wasn't ju you know like
there was obviously we keep making fun
of slipknot and i'm going to make fun of
slipknot for the end of time uh both the
band and the man oh
um but yeah so it definitely like it
felt like the all the deaths mattered in
this and it was uh it was more fun i
knew going into it was going to be fun
and this is one of those ones where
normally when there's something where
there's so much hype around it i like to
give it some space we couldn't because
we had to make an honest trailer so we
had to watch it um and so i this one
definitely lived up to the height for me
and that isn't very that doesn't happen
very often just because i get so hyped
up in my own brain that by the time i
see it i'm like it was fine it was
whatever but this one lived up to the
hype for me i thought it was really fun
and i really had a good time watching
yeah um and and i'll say this is an
example of uh an honest trailer where we
were
largely positive um largely supportive
of the film because that's the series
we're we're honest about it we're not
just like trying to take it apart just
because it's funnier and it is usually
funnier when it's a bad movie but i
think that we did an okay job uh sliding
right along and and hopefully making it
making you chuckle so let's let's dive
into the honest trailer four the suicide
squad
don't get it
what's the spoiler window on the
streaming movie these days
there is there is no no there is none
from that's not some people just talk
about it right now release
but are holding firm with david ayer
fans no we are not going down this road
again i don't care what happened on a
submarine wait what happened on a
submarine comes the film that only
exists because look i know like every
every film is a huge labor of love and
and and life lost to to the movie-making
process but lana i think your
observation was like
regardless of david air's story and his
his hardscrabble roots and the heartfelt
uh message he posted this was a movie
about a clown lady fighting a skype yeah
they didn't deserve the gravitas that
we're talking about it with right people
were people got mad at me after that
tweet because they were like how dare
you make fun of david ayers trauma like
i'm not the one bringing up his trauma
as it relates to the 2016 field of
suicides but that's him he's doing that
it yeah it's a it's it's weird that
that's the one where you're like my
artistic vision was so important that
the dancing witch lady and her brother
the lava guy had to fight the the you
know cholo with flame powers and it's
just like this is the project that
you're so committed to like you made you
know you wrote training day you made
fury because you made you know real
movie i guess we'll never know we got to
see that air cut to find out what maybe
buried within there is is well we know
now that uh deadshot and harley quinn
had a romance uh story that was written
out that's that's the latest revelation
yeah like a picture of them making out
leaked and i'm like what is this from
behind the scenes or is this like a real
phone
yeah this is just that it's fine jada is
cool with it
all right i'm really looking forward to
margot robbie on red table talk that's
going to be a great episode
james gone made one too many pedo tweets
for disney and dc swooped in like come
on home gunny boy let the jizz jokes fly
it's like angels are splooting all low
for
the suicide squad
what is this movie
some kind of
suicide squad
yes but also no get ready for the same
basic premise but a massively different
direction
so pause just briefly um a little bit of
crosspromo
fandom.com
i'm not exactly sure how to find it
maybe we put the link in the description
uh kim who you know from sju wrote an
article about the feasibility of
actually implanting a bomb in someone's
head and setting it off oh yeah i'll put
that in the description yeah yeah um
turns out
like you could do it but it'd be a lot
bulkier than you know just the little
injection because you need a battery you
need a power source you need a
transmitter you need more stuff than
fits in the base of a skull sorry right
they like to do it where it's just
they always like to make it look like
the whole bomb is like the size of like
a pill and they can just put it in it's
like that's not you know like yeah we
can make things tiny but not that right
it would look more like the thinker than
um than just like a grain of rice or
something like that uh okay keep going
replacing figurative jokes with actual
jokes endless character introductions
with no character introductions and
changing the title from suicide squad to
the suicide squad see there's a little
duh on the poster so everyone knows it's
a new movie with a bunch of the same
characters oh boy no wonder this bombed
welcome boss actors uh short of like not
having a global pandemic what what do
you guys think we they should have done
to give this movie a better chance at
success
oh
is it doomed
no i think it would have been a bigger
movie but it's also like it's it's
r-rated it's an r-rated superhero comedy
the word got out that it was pretty gory
like i think even with um
even with a deadpool where like you know
like it didn't have just the level of
nudity and gore and penises like it
didn't have all of those things and i
think that once word got out because
like there's some r-rated movies that
people will still bring their kids to if
it's just like language and violence but
once you start getting into dangling
like that's when you feel like it
becomes a problem like when you start
getting into stuff swinging around um so
i i don't and not that it was we can't
blame it all on full frontal nudity and
gore but i do think that that's a lot of
it where people might be like ah this
one might not be for me
in terms of just like if we're just if
we're just talking content and not all
of the other stuff around what goes into
marketing
yeah yeah i i it just it's it's a sequel
to a movie like the first one did well
like i get why they wanted to do a
sequel because it made a lot of money
but it was not well received it's not
like a movie that five years later
people are still talking about in a
upbeat way when are we
there's a pocket of people who like but
um yeah so it feels like already you're
kind of starting from like okay well we
got to like sell this again to people
but then you're also not bringing back
will smith like every time we've seen
them try to do here's a sequel to a
thing you liked with will smith but
we've removed the will smith oh yeah
thanks that's a great black
international your independence
dependency resurgence yeah
it tends to not connect and i think that
you never want like not everything that
has will smith in it becomes a huge hit
but
people do like that guy when you start a
franchise with will smith yeah they they
lose the will to live after after the
first right
and and i think that it's not like this
one like obviously margot robbie a draw
her third film is harley quinn but other
than that it i don't know that they
replaced will smith with a will smith
level draw like i love idris alba i
think john cena is great there's a lot
of fun characters it's got a great cast
this movie but there isn't a
a marquee name like a will smith on it
and i think those two things just really
hurt it like sequel to a movie that a
lot of people didn't love and it's
lacking the big name star it's like well
yeah that's not going to do as well yeah
i think
i just don't think i think us on the
internet we hear james gunn and we're
like oh guardians like great i can't
wait to see this i i don't know if all
the normies are like that i think you
gotta sell them a little harder it
doesn't pass the mom test like i go by
what what it and because my mom's like
pretty genre savvy but like she's
getting lesser as there's more of it
more but now and she's like a person
with responsibilities and a will smith
that's something that my mom knows james
gunn my mom doesn't necessarily that
takes a little bit of explaining um
and i think there's much of an
explaining for this one
and if you're on twitter all day you
assume everybody has the level of
knowledge of all of these films that you
have and everybody's geared up for the
guardians guy to jump over to dc and do
suicide squad but i don't know if it
translates to the everyday person who's
just deciding what to see this weekend
yeah i don't know what they i don't
personally don't know what they could
have done better i think calling it task
force x or maybe trying to distance it
more from the first suicide squad could
have sparked a little more interest but
really i i got to blame the rona on this
one i i think that if we could have all
packed into theaters and been like
laughing and barfing along with uh with
everything that was happening that uh
you would have had more positive word of
mouth and more people going back uh ryan
put in the chat thomas peterson says hbo
max also killed repeat viewings for this
i think this is a movie that people
would have gone to see more than once uh
lon you said you watched it like three
or four times in the first couple days
right yes
in those first two days yeah yeah so i
don't know i think this is this will be
a great uh when things are back open
like a midnight movie yeah that they can
play different places i could totally
see this at the new beverly or what have
you so
i think you definitely have to like if
you're talking about how much it would
have grows you definitely have to take
the hbo max into account tons of people
are watching these movies at home and
not going to the theater i do think it's
interesting to note that mortal kombat
did almost as well as suicide squad in
theaters and more people if you look at
the samba tv numbers who knows how
accurate it is it looks like more people
may have watched mortal kombat on hbo
mac so i do think there was a
there was a dip in interest in this
movie versus where you'd maybe think of
james gunn comic book movie with john
cena well then i really think it's it's
the name and it's the um it's just the
normies like just looking at you're on
hbo max and you see the suicide squad
and it's like the poster kind of looks
the key art kind of looks the same oh
there's harley quinn like i've seen this
movie i didn't like it
i thought
a crocodile man not a shark man yeah
yeah it's been five years it's mandela
effect things berenstain
all right keep going
welcome back actors eager to watch the
stank off their last outing as these
characters like viola davis bringing way
too much talent and pedigree to a film
with pete davidson in it okay joel
kinnaman who somehow makes you care
about rick flag to the point where his
death hits the hardest i blame you
katada you're supposed to have his back
where was katana and of course margot
robbie in her third appearance fully
quinn and there's a wildly different
version of the character going from
stripper scipies to self-actualized
badass to a twee romantic with a head
full of flowers and birds who still
manages to steal the film in a sequence
full of torture dead goons and close-up
foot stuff or as tarantino calls it
i mean
at least three different writers so you
know it makes sense that it'd be
slightly different takes in the
character i feel like her in this film
was really just a setup for that like
sight gag of her shooting the guy in the
chest and i think it was worth it i
think it it's a great payoff i don't
really care that it doesn't doesn't
super mesh well with the last two what'd
you guys think of harley quinn this film
i'd like that big speech about you know
uh like that i thought that that was
really well done the big speech about
red flags and then shooting the guy was
great they did give her a great action
sequence because you have to kind of if
you're gonna get margo robbie to come
back you have to give her like something
kind of meaty and that action sequence
was really well done i liked that we got
to get into her head and then like yeah
and her head was all like the flowers
and the birds and all that stuff um
but and you she does get kind of the kid
like you do feel like this movie like
knows that it has to serve hardly in a
way
but it this isn't
it isn't necessarily to serve her as far
as character work goes but as far as
like we know that we need to make her an
important part of the movie so like they
launched the the huge thing to make them
go back and get her she gets
like you know at least half of the
credit for the killing blow in the last
scene and so it does feel like they you
know but it's also it's harley so it's
she never feels like she belongs super
in these movies with meta humans just
because like she doesn't really have any
powers other than being super duper pale
because the acid
um she's unpredictable danielle you
can't she's she's got that yeah you
can't tell where she's going next she's
cooperating
she's she's good at fighting she's got
the baseline she's like very good at
fighting i think my ass yeah yeah i i i
don't know to me and i like this movie
overall as a total package better than
birds of prey but i still feel like
kathy yann's really the only one to like
totally get how to do harley quinn as a
live-action character like the opening
30 minutes of birds of prey is as pure
as we've ever had like the margot robbie
harley quinn like that that feels like
the character this one i don't know i
like i i liked a lot of this stuff but i
don't know it doesn't really necessarily
feel to me like james gunn gets
who this is she's just like this chaotic
lady presence in a bunch of his movie
and it almost feels like she's changing
sometimes like scene to scene like i
like the animated birds and flowers
think of the way it looked but i don't
like what does that have to do with
anything
anything else about harley quinn that
we've ever learned see i felt like
because they did so much pulling back
and birds of prey where harley doesn't
really get too many kills like she's not
really killing anybody she's got like
slitter guns and like funny clown tricks
right she's like knocking him on the
noggins yeah to me it felt like a way of
excusing her violence because she is
like she has an extreme kill count in
this movie and to me i felt like that
was a way of them being able to be like
oh well in her head it's not blood it's
birds and flowers and so maybe she
doesn't like get the impact of all of
the murdering that she's doing so that
if they do do another movie with her
where it is like another one geared
towards girls where she isn't quite as
violent they can be like oh well harley
doesn't know what she's doing like that
like it felt like almost no i don't want
to say like it's a cop out because i
thought that it was really good but it
almost felt like it was a way to kind of
have it both ways where she's both this
maniacal clown killing lady and also you
get to say like oh well her head's just
batty she doesn't really like get that
she's murdering this house right that's
her super i think it's like a country
i think i think both air and now gun
that i think that exactly drills into it
it's like they're they're they're trying
to have them both wait she's she's evil
psycho lady joker
but she's also like funny and charming
and you want her around she's not really
like that bad she's in the world twice
yeah and like that's what this film kind
of feels like it's like whatever he
needed for this scene is like that's
where harley's head is at right now and
like that's fine she's fun in the role
but i don't know like it didn't feel to
me like
it felt like birds are prey really like
oh okay now i get who this character is
then this one is kind of like
ah she's in a red dress now that looks
cool right
uh well
uh
you can you can see how she fares
against the joker across his films in
another video on this very channel joke
versus harley quinn by the numbers uh
you might be surprised who wins harley
in most things oh i spoiled it dang it
still click still give it a click uh all
right let's let's keep watching joker's
not really about number he's not a
numbers guy he racks up a lot of
economic damage so it's that it's that
four billion dollar pyramid in the dark
knight that right really gets them over
the top okay but he's more about the
emotional impact
it's not quantifying
but forget the og squad not that they
ever can there's a whole new aside squad
in town featuring idris elba as will
smith said no to the sequel i mean
bloodsport this other sharpshooter on a
mission to save his daughter will have
audiences everywhere wondering if
there's a draft of the script that still
has deadshot's name on it
john cena's peacemaker the kind of guy
dwight schrute imagines himself to be he
does exactly what i do but better i am
better than you have ever been or ever
will be
i think john cena
to date
way better in comedic roles than like
act standard action
heavy roles um granted i haven't seen
the whole marine franchise just the
first one but i think that's the only
one he's in i don't think yeah he's not
in the whole marine france oh okay okay
the rest of them are a different
wrestler a different version yeah
but between this and blockers uh versus
the marine and f9 i really like funny
cena uh he's wasted if you don't use
them in like a comedic role
i'm at that stage
yeah heart agree
yeah it was weird that they made him so
severe in f9 it's like that feels so out
of i know he's a wrestler but that just
feels so out of character for him to be
so glum the whole movie i'm hoping there
it's going to be one of those well he's
a terrific next one
in the next one he gets to join the good
guys and then he'll develop a personnel
that's usually what happens man well
we'll get it into that soon um okay
anyways keep going keep going and a guy
cursed with exploding polka dots on the
outside and the mental state of your
typical incel on the inside ratcatcher 2
who gets dismissed as a lazy millennial
millennials but i'm pretty sure she just
has mono we're tired colonel we need a
rest
[Music]
so sleepy
you guys made that joke
no the other one
some glorified characters
james gunn's buddies a nice payday i
assume i just missed you actually
threatening animal sidekick since the
last three cute but actually threatening
animal sidekicks please please please
give us behind the scenes of stallone's
video sessions for this i need it new
dumb friends
follow the smiley crew of outcasts as
they do an adorkable version of the bay
of pigs featuring an extended massacre
of freedom fighters play for laughs
i mean it was hilarious
weiner out cause when the usa has to do
a good old-fashioned i mean this this
film was like
look with the politics let's say we're
muddled we're a little bit muddled
not that i'm looking for a suicide squad
film to like really uh you know
it's spelled out for me
it's always that thing it's like you
could use these movies to kind of
comment on the larger socio-political
issues that you want to talk about but
at the end they can't ever like
side with not america because it's an
american you know you're an american
company you're making movies in america
with american actors and so yeah
there always is this weird
like this really starts off with a
really interesting sort of perspective
about how we go and you know just go
after whatever we want in these other
countries and blow up and kill off
whoever and we just have our mission and
the welfare of anyone around or anything
having to do with that mission doesn't
matter like that's an interesting sort
of attack for a comic book movie to make
but then you know the third act we've
always got to get back to just like
all right go good thing we're here so we
can save the world from yeah like go
into the facility and kill the big
threat to the city and the fact that the
fact that everybody in corto maltese is
just like wiped out and dead and there's
nothing we can do and like
just thousands die during the climax of
this movie and it's not really discussed
is a little weird and it's always the
idea that like well if the right people
were in charge like these are it's still
good to have a suicide squad as long as
mean old amanda waller isn't calling the
shots
right it's never like right
we've been yeah it was it was there yeah
the only problem was that she was making
she was mean one bad decision yeah she's
a mean mean lady and you have to conquer
upside the head yeah if aj were running
it the whole time it'd be great
anywho keep going
amanda waller won't hesitate to build a
team with one crucial thing in common
traumatic parent stuff my father's
burdens
i came to heavy to carry my old man one
day he just
locked me in a crate for 24 hours and it
was full of starving rats his father was
a soldier who trained his son how to
kill from the moment he was born my
mother was a scientist at star lab so
she was obsessed with turning me and my
brothers and sisters into superheroes
she infected me
and we don't really know what's up with
harley quinn's dad but come on it's
nothing good right oh pause yes we got
something wrong
uh birds of prey they say that uh their
dad traded her for a six pack of beer
but i say that harley is not the most
reliable narrator i don't think we
really know what was involved in that
six-pack exchange yeah right that seems
like hyperbole
um but
technically yeah we knew we know
about what happened with her dad and
it's not good but what happened before
she could have been 24 he could have
been like you got to get out of the
house i'm trying to university maybe the
vibes weren't right sometimes a baby
just has bad vibes and you've got to get
rid of that bad bye baby that's not true
danielle you can't get rid of your baby
for bad vibes
not a thing
uh but yeah um
anyways uh so sorry we'll we'll we'll do
a full rewrite um
for the next uh the next suicide squad
reboot i i'm not sorry
i don't feel like i do not feel bad
about this at all
great all right moving on serious case
of daddy issues you all do even the
guardians all do james gunn hates dads
when thanos took my homeworld he killed
my parents in front of me every time my
sister prevailed
my father would replace a piece of me
with machinery just like my own damn
parents who sold me throw little babies
into slavery
hilarious violence
[Music]
dicks a gen xers greatest hits mixtape
chapter headings that make you say ooh
disgusting animals that make you say oh
and a finale where rats eat a giant
eyeball that doesn't make you say
come on people see this movie why
couldn't they just call it suicide squad
we're sorry and we promise we did better
this time
there you go we're just unapologetically
telling you to go
the guy who can flag anything
i'm going to become the poker
will smith
why are you showing a blank screen
there's nothing oh i get it
rocky shark doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo paws
you
uh
you animals he finally got us to do it
because every time we do john cena and
his starring it's like why didn't you do
the joke about how you can see yeah
all right fine there you go we're never
doing it again all right keep going
color be bad
the dick of it astaro is born
saturday narc dies
i'm married
and the air cut who are you going to
show that to god damn people deserve no
i'm going to need that drive colonel no
one is saying
that information gets out it causes an
international incident
uh we should have put like some sort of
warner brothers logo on peacemaker there
or something like that
made him uh exec anyways yeah keep going
suicide squad we're sorry and we
promised we did better this time
it takes everyone way too long to figure
out the anti-sorrow strategy is just
cover your face feels like that would be
kind of your first reflex if a big
starfish was flying straight at it you
can even keep holding your gut i'll just
yeah
see one guy could get the face
they show the suicide squad doing it and
they're literally just like like doing
this it's just yeah they're just not
that hard waving at it and they're
bouncing off of them yeah just
all the soldiers are like
that's that's the wrong approach yeah
that's definitely gonna get you in
trouble yeah
uh anywho that's the suicide squad um a
film that i think is really fun and um
pretty silly and doesn't deserve the
deepest uh the deepest dive except to
say that uh i enjoyed it and i would
like to see it in a theater at some
revival some uh uh some years from today
it was good i liked it
um
like a good double feature with uh
slither that's what i was gonna say oh
yeah because they both like that the
gross out cartoonish gore james gunn
stuff yeah michael rivers well they're
so gross perfect so there's really
um
i hope you guys feel the same way about
this video that you're watching that's
pretty good and you do it again uh so
click subscribe click like click the
bell you know how it works uh and you'll
never miss another thing we have some
outtakes uh we cut some stuff let's see
what we cut from the suicide squad
jai courtney showing up just long enough
to remind us that we like jai courtney
now
still manages to steal the film in a
sequence full of torture dead goons and
close-up foot stuff we call that the
full tarantino or as tarantino calls it
john cena's peacemaker the kind of guy
dwight schrute imagines himself to be i
always hear my target's dead center get
them more in the center something more
in a sense i use smaller bullets what
they go inside your bullet holes without
even touching the side i am fast
to give you a reference point i'm
somewhere between a snake and a mongoose
and a panther are you trying to hurt my
feelings because if so you are
succeeding
fortunately my feelings regenerate at
twice the speed of a normal lens okay i
am better than you have ever been or
ever will be
i cherish peace with all my heart i
don't care how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it
there's too many people on this earth we
need a new flag we'll have to wait for
his spin-off series to learn why he was
in prison in the first place but you get
the feeling he has to tell people about
it when he moves into a new neighborhood
but this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks if somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problemo
and the cutest actually threatening
animal sidekick since the last three
cute but actually threatening animal
sidekicks king shark good king shark
stallone's best role since creed and
starring
colonel america
flagamin bagum
living single
plot lemur
birds of jay
stringer bellrave look at me i'm black
mega man the maltese falcon
alien
self-annihilation chrome mender
seen enough
you can't cease me
do the right wing
landshark jabber jaws
limitless
rat girl
fear dot mob pow po po papoka dot phase
how to get away with several dozen
murders
doctor screwed chocolate starfish
this is milton he's got my back i'd
advise not killing him
but don't touch
long-ass guns
let's just keep getting longer
why would you want a thing that spins
oops just deadpools
to a side squad
dc get your gun
there you go uh yeah that's a that's a
huge um oversight on our part to not put
that milton one in there which is funny
yeah
that's the uh premise of the films that
they keep forgetting him he was great
love him hope he's back uh oh wait he
can't well pretty cool he's dead yeah
all right on to the
um he probably had a great dad he
probably did not have any parent stuff
to speak up very loving nothing
supportive yeah makes even sadder um
okay the questions evan jay pretzel
asked i really enjoyed polka dot man and
guns reinvention of him do we see the
character again and this is change on
par with mr freeze and batman the
animated series like taking a sort of
corny silly villain and making him
making him legit
i think he's pretty dead
he definitely is dead i mean i guess we
could do a prequel
you know yeah you know they can
they can always find a way he was he was
in prison so he must be but you could
put it like would you do a different
version of him in like the batman or
something just because people seem to
respond to him and and he's not there's
a there's a smart way to do the
character again i don't see it i think
this was one-off yeah i mean
the joke is that his power is not very
useful he just fires these little like
explosive-y polka dot things and uh yeah
how much mileage can you really like mr
freeze there's a lot you could do with a
guy who has ice powers that's like a
classic comic trope
not quite so much with a guy with polka
dot power yeah yeah that's also a little
more tragic than i just see my mom
everywhere
yeah uh all right works great for this
movie
here comes some real advice uh maybe the
wrong uh people to ask but hey we'll try
arthur mingo asks hey uh here's my
question what advice do you people have
for a writer director doing his first
short film i'm that guy
i
don't know i don't really make sure i
guess we make short videos but i haven't
made a short film since like college
find a way to give me money i find a way
to get money
and then use that money
okay if you can get somebody to give you
a lot of money that would be great i
know that there's been other advice
that's been like maxed out your credit
cards i don't agree with that advice
yeah don't use your own money if you can
um
perhaps try the malaysian development
fund if there's anything left in there
after uh after that scandal but i don't
know what to what to tell you um
lonnie got anything
i mean look you know i think it's so
it's so hard to get people's attention
and i think that there's so many things
you can focus on when you're when you're
making a short film but you don't want
to just focus on you want to make
something that that you want and that
you like that but i i think that having
one element there where whether it's the
title something about the premise a shot
a cool thing that you do having one
thing that people could grab onto that's
like why am i going to share this with
my friend why am i going to tweet this
why am i going to post this on whatever
it is is a thing to think about when
you're in that early creative process
like what's the one element of this
that's going to stand out because
there's so many shorts out there in the
world that it helps to have a a nugget
of something memorable that people can
grab up oh i have one
yeah that i think is really important
listen to notes get notes from people
that you trust
um
i i
i it's great that we all want to be our
tours and have our one singular vision
but like if you know people who are good
at writing things get notes from them
and maybe you agree with them or maybe
you don't but notes of only they hurt
and it sucks but they've only ever made
my writing better when i've had people
like trust actually give me real things
um that can tighten up a script or
answer questions or anything like that
so like get notes
yeah in general like collaborators like
the more people you have around you who
are also smart and passionate and and
interested in what you're doing the
better so whether they're people reading
over your script or helping you put the
film together or whatever like tap as
many potential extra brains as you can i
would say
you're here
i will only add if it's your first film
a short film and it sucks that's fine
it's your first one make another one
um okay great ryan ryan adds in the chat
uh talk to an editor before you film so
you know what shots you need yeah if you
have a shot list beforehand that that
that doesn't hurt that definitely helps
yes all right back to the real stuff uh
panther ass uh make a suicide squad with
marvel villains who do you pick let's
just do three you get a three three
villain squad
who are you picking from uh from the
marvel universe to to send on a certain
death mission
oh god i'm trying to think of who
they're like really crappy b-squad
c-squad
right
my my star is funko i'm i'm taking funko
off the board um and his bird
that counts
yeah you get you get both in one there
is that fair yeah yeah
um abomination i'll say you can add the
bomb after that you need yeah i mean
it's look we need like a bigger a bigger
dude who can go through and do some
stuff and do some damage um i know that
he's maybe a bigger villain but yeah
that's right let's throw a nomination in
there i'm gonna go with ronin the
accuser just because i think there's a
lot of comedy to be mined from all of
the other characters making fun of his
big stupid hammer yeah and yeah i
constantly walks around with even when
he's just like in his own ship just like
it's like a judge's gavel because he's
the accuser he's like
but it's literally the size of him
i just in captain marvel there's that
scene where he's just like standing on
the ship talking to another guy and he's
just holding it for no we're like that's
so happy put it you'd put it down give
us at least one like jacques like some
reason for him to like have the
objections right yeah so then all like
right like he makes phoenix right
gestures all the time i'm in i'm in for
that but yeah like him walking around
like a jungle with a bunch of other
characters he's got this massive space
hammer i think it's fine okay we're
doing this snake draft style so long you
you get to go again then it'll go down
no no that's not fair okay fine
okay
uh i'm gonna do uh quicksilver from one
division like the bro uncle
uncle quicksilver oh okay uh yeah so
wait is he is he still mind controlled
or he's you know he's ralph boner you
know whatever whatever the script
dictates he's ralph boner yeah
the actor ralph boner uh is joining ivan
vonko on my suicide squad
love that yeah danielle i'll go next um
speaking of captain marvel i don't
remember uh jude law's uh character name
um but definitely that like fight me
debate me dude debate me dude yeah
debate me guy yeah yeah debate me guy
let's have him on the squad why not like
he's he's kind of a fighter he's got a
few like little special like you know
things that he can do um plus you know
no one knows
no at all which makes him the perfect
person for a suicide squad because no
one remembers him except for him being
jubal's character that tries to
challenge john wrong
yeah
uh i got mine deacon frost tell me you
don't want a like from a vampire yeah
deacon frost dwarf man steven dorff as
an aging for some reason he's getting
much older even though he's a vampire uh
hates hates day walkers he's on the
mission
okay
uh crap so i'm up um yeah hmm so i've
got uh i've got uh ralph boner i've got
ivan funko
um
i think i'm gonna pair them with someone
like uh
who's um
you know thanos's like guy who's like
uh ebony
[Laughter]
kind of the rounding out i think we got
a good balance of personalities power
levels uh uh i think that's that's my
three-person squad do we all pick three
uh
yeah i've only picked two uh who is the
dude in ant-man jackfruit uh jackknife
uh uh yellow jacket yellow jacket yeah
let's do yellow jacket we get one dude
with some good armor um he's angry he's
bald oh i wanna i wanna re-pick after
that um i want the uh uh walton goggins
from ant-man 2.
the entrepreneur
just an entrepreneur with a dream um
okay yeah sorry go ahead i like i like i
like that um yeah i mean like it's
tempting to just go uh alligator loki at
this point i feel like he would be a he
would be a terrific uh third addition to
any any any squad so i think that's what
i'm going
all right uh let us know in the chat
what uh what your favorite slash what
your own three-person uh marvel suicides
oh okay one more vinnie jones as the
juggernaut from the x-men how can i
blank on that one if we're going past
the mcu which i guess you have with your
dwarf pick uh i guess that's that's
marvel he just said marvel fair enough
right
um okay i'm the juggernaut [ __ ]
bring that memorable moment back uh nate
turtle has a a important question
because this was kind of the premise of
the first one um do you think this new
suicide squad can take on superman
not a chance
is there anyone
apparently uh dead blood sport dead shot
blood sport whatever i like i literally
failed yeah
shoot him with a kryptonite bullet yeah
no i don't think i mean chance
no batman v superman what weapon almost
took him out a little bit of kryptonite
at the end of a long stick who now owns
a long stick harley quinn so yeah we're
kind of if she gets a little bit of
kryptonite dipped on the end of javelin
and uh she's ready to go yeah
uh okay and now we'll we'll we'll close
out with this the the most imp there's
probably some good questions past this
but i'm just fixated on this one reynard
city update channel asks who would win
in the fight winnie the pooh sonic the
hedgehog or rupert the bear
which one's rupert yeah who's rupert the
bear is like a uk only okay
this is totally like
yeah that looks really in cartoon
extremely british wow
he's out
i put in howard the duck and his howard
the duck
god uh well i mean sonic is your is your
go-to because he's he's
sonic he's got super speed
um
we need the poo is useless in a fight in
a throwdown unless there's honey on the
line
oh there's hiding on the line a tree
yeah he's got an addiction so if there's
honey on the line like he's definitely
going you just pour yours for the
enemies and honey and then he goes
berserk
totally but
yeah tigger's the can-do guy from that
bunch could howard the duck beat sonic
the hedgehog
he could sardonic quit him today
it's like
yeah maybe
all right well um not as not as hot of a
movie fight as i thought it would be but
that's why i don't do the show anymore
um
let's wrap this up uh i'm so excited for
you guys to come back next week um
because we are uh we're getting to
something that we should have done
ways back um
but you know what uh sometimes
you never expect
i can't say
should i just give it away or what could
anyone think of a good tease for next
week because i can't
ryan says vroom yeah very brutal vroom
vroom but you can't guess what it is um
all right
that's our show for today from our
family to yours yes vroom vroom
now
all right thanks for watching watch our
other videos we'll see you later bye-bye
this episode was brought to you by who
[Music]
you